vous n'avez jamais travaillé
regardez-moi droit dans les yeux
regardez moi combien vous touchez par
mois combien vous touchez par mois
jordan bardella répondait aux français
je vous reviens je touche par maury mais
dans les naulleau c'est madame emond
c'est
oublier coup sous la ceinture vous serez
bientôt premier ministe de zemmour
laissez moi parler avec jordan d'accord
beaucoup d'efforts
[Applaudissements]
vous toucher mon salaire de député
européen il est public combien défaut
finalement élu pour cela qu'il est si
les français ils font ici si les
français qui sont ici soit de se
renseigner sur le salaire des démunis
des européens ils vont se rendre chez
rusal en tête mais demandez à votre
voyage au départ d'un parlementaire ou
bien jean paul garraud répond non mais
je voudrais d'abord répondre et c'est le
fait très important le niveau et ses
treize
fois je rembourse irrigue merci
pour la paix la vérité notre ambition
vous sachiez ici il se prend pour un
cadeau après il va rentrer chez lui
valait sur twitter il va essayer de
faire croire
rien de l'histoire de ce pays de quelque
chose elle se croit toujours que tu es
de gauche quoi j'ai séjourné en mai chez
jamais pour le rassemblement national
vous et moi tu voteras poser
complètement tu voteras pour ses mots
zemmour est candidat ah bah ça y est
maintenant dans ta bouche et plus
candidat il n'est pas jusqu'à quand je
vais te dirai ensuite dans les bureaux
de vote soit à vue qu'avait un isoloir
l'homme et eric je vais te dire quelque
chose la seule chose du vin doux doux tu
me traites de fachos doute une autre
regard d'autres gars devant des millions
de français me faire faire ton coming
out devant tout le monde ah oui je suis
fier 4h au passage on est toujours sur
sa liste ça s'est avéré que maintenant
elle me regarde
tu le vrai sujet le grand reprenne avec
jean collin et la salle était de
l'émission complètement sorti
sa vie à parler des jeux et grotesque
mais comment
rien qu'en une autre dans le couloir tu
veux bien vous touche attention on va
voir qui va partir on abat n'en faut pas
moins à travers
des mecs comme toi c'est bon vous avez
vu je redonne la racaille n'est pas
toujours là où on le pense
ces mois-ci d'héberger
les
cahiers c'est beau